at 10 13 this morning the police
department received a call of an active
shooter inside Covenant School
please pray so hard for these families a
tragedy unfolds in Nashville after a
mass shooting left at least six people
dead three of them children police say
officers have shot and killed the person
who opened fire inside a private school
country stars are speaking out in the
aftermath sharing their reactions to
social media following the massacre on
what's known as the country music
Capital it's just
what is happening in the world for Jesse
James Decker it hits closer to home than
most a lot of you are messaging it it's
not it's not my kid's school but it's
only two miles up the road I wouldn't
pick the kids up immediately and they're
home safe it's in our town it's in our
community please pray so hard for these
families in this community this is just
should not be happening we know that she
was armed with at least two assault type
rifles and a handgun among the reactions
emotional please for gun reform Sheryl
Crow on Twitter our children deserve
better and Cassidy Pope I'm sick to my
stomach these were babies how is this
still happening it is just awful I'm
just so heartbroken for these families
many like Mickey Guyton are calling out
legislators shame on every single
politician okay with doing nothing
schools should be safe spaces for our
kids to grow and learn the White House
echoing these calls to action we want to
express the president's appreciation for
the First Responders and prayers for all
the families affected by this shooting
while we don't know yet all the details
in this latest tragic shooting we know
that too often our schools and
communities are being devastated by gun
violence we must do more and he wants
Congress to act
thank you